[Music]
good morning guys today is January 12
2009 teen which means it's Isaac's
birthday if you just turned 11 I cannot
believe it my kids 11 years old it's so
insane
so that's my I think had two of his
bestest friends come over first
sleepover so Mike amethyst they're both
here and they came over to sleepover
because today on Isaac's actual birth
they were heading over to Knott's Berry
Farm I thought it was really cute that
Isaac was like nah mommy don't worry
about throwing me a party cuz last year
we had a laser tag party you think now
don't worry about that I just want my
two friends to come over and us to go to
a theme park he actually wanted
Disneyland but I'm like favorite Disney
Land it's so expensive it's like
literally twice the price of not so he
was like oh it's okay we don't have to
go to Disneyland we can go or not it's
alright he's such a sweet kid oh my
goodness he's so thoughtful cuz he
thinks about these things you know cuz
kids usually don't really care about
like the price or any of that stuff but
he's such a sweet kid so he was like no
it's okay doesn't matter I just want to
have fun with my friends oh my god
Hilary so so anyway so yeah they were
big slept over last night they were
playing around in a Tesla it was so cute
because I think was like so eager to
show them the new Tesla I even posted on
my story too I was just like yeah like
we pulled down the seats we were laying
down so Isaac is in the middle of a
sleepover and he wanted to show the
Tesla to the kids and look at this all
five of us are in this cart we put the
seats down where's Casey and now they're
playing the Atuk game Isaac's driving
maybe a few more years before you can
drive huh
and they were just playing games and
video games because they'll have
switches so they're playing on this way
and then I got Isaac super smash bros
ultimate or something like that for his
birthday and I feel yeah so last night
Casey was working really late last night
on our vlogs a second Hong Kong vlog
because he was up finishing up that
video I can go to see how waited up for
him we didn't end up going to sleep
until almost 4:00 in the morning cuz
it's that video took forever so Casey
and I ended up we're sleeping a bit in
the morning I know it sounds bad but
Isaac was so sweet he woke up in the
morning with his friends and he made
them breakfast like he actually made
them an omelette I was like why by the
time I got about like oh my goodness you
made the breakfast already he was like a
mommy was easy there's no problem like
oh my gosh he's such a big kid let's go
say happy birthday to the birthday boy
oh how funny they're playing with the
romantic fireplace you're so silly happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday I'm trying really hard to
show you my singing skills you're very
nice
hey I appreciate it maybe you didn't
want to do your hair for your birthday
yeah you're tired - well here's Mathis
and Mikey you guys are tired - you're
like get the camera out of my face okay
I get it you're excited for nod yeah
woohoo are you gonna get on the ride
yeah yeah
don't die probably no you're you're
gonna be fine annoying you good knowing
you
we're heading over to not and the boys
wanted to action it makes me nervous
gets rainy - I'm like Tesla eight or
nine minutes ugly but hovering over the
brakes just in case they do have ads on
the world script adjust
I just turn it off just to put your
[Music]
I was a rollercoaster awesome have the
first roller coaster of the day I was
actually a very very fun so we went on
Ghost Rider knows the first ride of the
day we waited a long time but if they
wanted like the bigger kid right right
so throughout the entire time in the
line I think was actually go should I
not go should I do it should I not do it
and I'm like okay I'm done peer
pressuring you for rides you can go if
you want so you make your own decision
and then so finally he was like okay
I'll do it
and so we sit down and finally heels
like we wanted it too late is it too
late I'm like maybe it's too late like
your puppy fell on like you're committed
after we did the whole ride here like
that was so much fun like you think I
told you he was like yeah waiting in
line is the hardest part
cousin you get really scared
the photo at the end of this video
Casey could do a whole like montage
thingy of the photos good idea better
we're letting the kids be the tour
guides of Knott's Berry Farm today
[Music]
I got hat here too for the rest of the
day doing your - the luckiest guy ever
here's my head yeah you found your house
thank you so much
I know she actually found it and saved
it for you you're so lucky we're about
to look for an oz hat you're about to
spend like 30 bucks on a random but it
was that we said but then I don't know
where he was like good I mean lesson now
we see him like to talk and walk his
friends and I'm like I'm telling Casey
I'm like well
he knows where he's going in life
year-old
[Music]
age where kids started thinking that
they own the world's and next side of my
mind you know like
I remember thinking like there's nothing
left I can learn in this closed
so funny like in remembering we have
don't know anything
[Music]
criminy did they just announced another
delay ding every been waiting in this
line and they keep an amount easily
another spell people are weird
this right is grand news like slowly
at Johnny Rockets inside the theme park
Oh
then you got the Lotus fries
Oh
all right how was your birthday today
yeah where's your favorite part today
Ghost Rider Ghost Rider we did a two
times daily yeah yeah was it way more
fun to have your friends here what is
your purpose at home Viking your
birthday pre-war no we can't ever have a
pool party for your birthday what do we
do last year laser tag year before that
yeah I think was nice they say we shake
nuts and before that I don't remember
hey guys
you think you know these are voice from
all the roller roller coaster screaming
probably where does your voice never
comes back like you'd like right now
you're you have a go brassy voice in
that sky I wanna have a rest forever
no I'm saying like what if this is not
actually you having a raspy voice from
your roller coasters but it was actually
puberty hitting and then it's like you'd
be happy you want to have a deep voice
whatever man's voice oh say goodbye to
it cuz you only have a couple more years
anyway so enjoy your kiddies while alas
boy
Oh yours like huh what did you tell them
that we're doing something
what are we doing tonight I don't even
know well I mean there's something over
again oh yeah
so what's going on tonight I told you I
mean I could have just finished telling
oh yeah you finished all that man yeah
they're doing two sleepovers just gonna
be pretty cool it's like the entire
weekend yes he's been with his two
closest friends
sweet the first one was such a success
you guys are getting a sequel that's
awesome
[Laughter]
[Music]